[Música]
ah
el gobierno alemán explicó que son muy
alentadores los avances presentados por
el consorcio entre facer y bayón de que
su vacuna contra el coronavirus y mostró
su satisfacción en particular por el
hecho de que bayón teques sea una
empresa alemana aunque también las
autoridades en este país aseguraron que
sus avances no significan necesariamente
que la vacuna vaya a ser entregada muy
pronto de hecho las autoridades alemanas
esperan que la vacuna pueda ser
entregada a los alemanes a principios
del próximo año ya sea por ese consorcio
o por otros y por esa razón ya empezaron
las reparaciones específicas según el
gobierno alemán se espera que la vacuna
vaya a ser entregada en 60 centros
especializados alrededor del país y una
comisión establecida para tal efecto
determinó que muy probablemente se le
vaya a dar prioridad primero a las
personas que estén en grupos de alto
riesgo seguidos por las personas que
trabajan en el sector de salud y quienes
están en profesiones consideradas como
relevantes para la vida pública como por
ejemplo los policías o los profesores
[Música]
la eficacia de la vacuna rusa contra el
coronavirus es del 92% según los
primeros resultados la vacuna haya
atravesado sus dos primeras fases y
ahora se encuentra inmersa en la tercera
más de 16.000 rusos han recibido ya las
dos primeras dosis necesarias de esta
vacuna por la cual ya se han interesado
varios países latinoamericanos pero
también turquía que se ha ofrecido a
ayudar en su producción en masa la
sputnik 5 se administra en dos etapas en
un intervalo de 21 días entre una y otra
está en marcha una segunda vacuna y el
presidente ruso vladimir putin ha dicho
que rusia está a punto de registrar su
tercera vacuna contra la cob y 19
putin ha dicho que está dispuesto a
cooperar con otros países en materia de
vacunación aunque ha advertido contra la
politización de estos procesos rusia de
momento se resiste a cerrar todo el país
y pone todas sus esperanzas en una
amplia campaña de vacunación
[Música]
aunque la fase final de los ensayos
clínicos de cuatro vacunas chinas aún no
ha concluido se sabe que cientos de
miles de ciudadanos del país asiático
han sido inoculados con ellas esta
precampaña de vacunación que arrancó en
verano está destinada principalmente a
militares oa ciudadanos chinos que
tienen que trabajar o estudiar en el
extranjero se desconocen por el momento
tanto la efectividad real como los
efectos secundarios y el régimen chino
además ha prohibido hablar con los
medios a aquellos que las han recibido
los fabricantes sino pharmacy novak
cansino por su parte aseguran que sus
productos son seguros al tiempo que
muchos expertos advierten del peligro de
comenzar a administrar vacunas a gran
escala cuando aún no han concluido esos
ensayos clínicos cabe recordar que una
vez que terminen esas pruebas chinas se
ha comprometido a vender a varios países
de latinoamérica estas vacunas algo que
puede actuar como un impulso diplomático
en un momento en el que la imagen
exterior del país asiático no es la
mejor
[Música]